JASON TITUS: Hello and welcome.
My name is Jason Titus, and I
lead Google's developer product
group.
Our mission is to make your
lives easier as developers
when you build on
Google technologies.
And we are so excited
to be down here.
One of the reasons that our team
came down, beyond this event,
was actually to get a chance
to talk to developers here
in India.
And we've already got some
great feedback and insights
from teams like Snapdeal,
Grofers, Inshorts.
And then today, we've
had a great chance
to talk some developers here.
In fact, I believe we talked
to probably the youngest
developer in the room here,
Rashid, who has done 10 Android
apps as a 16-year-old.
And he snuck out of school today
to come and learn a little bit.
So that kind of passion and
excitement around development
and building apps is the
reason we do what we do.
So I want to talk a bit
about a transformation that's
happening, that India is
really in the center of.
Right now this year, we will
hit 2 billion mobile devices.
And by 2020 it's projected
to hit 3 billion.
And 50% of that growth will
come from India and China.
At the same time as the
number of users is growing,
the number of developers
is growing as well.
And in fact here in India,
we have the highest rate
of developer growth
in the world.
It's projected
that in 2017, India
will surpass the United States
in the number of developers.
So if you take these two things
combined and you pull back
a little bit, it
seems clear that many
of the people who are
in this room tonight
will be defining what
the experience is
for the next billion
users as they come online.
The opportunity is immense.
Whether you're building apps to
improve health care, education,
or enabling commerce, or
building next generation
entertainment
experiences, at Google
we're committed to build
the tools that you'll
need to be successful.
So we're going to talk
about three things
tonight-- programs
that we're investing in
to help you be
successful, products
that help you build your
apps and your business,
and information to help
you execute successfully
in this market.
First on the program
side, this morning Sundar
announced Google's commitment
to train 2 million students
in Android across India
over the next three years.
And this builds on a partnership
we've had with Udacity
to create an Android
Nanodegree program.
The Android Nanodegree
program helps
students go from being
beginners to building
their first step to
advanced development,
over the course of a few months.
And beyond our
formal curriculum,
we also have our Google
Developer Groups and our Google
Developer Experts.
I think there's a number of
you in this room tonight that
are a part of this.
And actually here in India,
we have the largest number
of Google Developer Group
members of any country.
You guys really raised the
bar for the rest of the world.
So if you're interested
in meeting an in person
network of other
developers, I encourage
you to attend one of the
events for the Google Developer
Group near you.
We've already had 3,000 events
in the last six months alone.
Another important
group of developers
are developer agencies.
And that's why I'm excited to
announce our Developer Agency
program.
These agencies build
many of our top apps.
And so we're putting
together a program
to give them specialized
training and events,
early access to product,
premium developer support,
as well as increased
opportunities for exposure
and visibility.
So the goal of this program is
to allow development agencies
to create top quality apps
and give them the opportunity
to build on top of
new technologies
as soon as they're released.
So in addition to
Android training,
things we're doing to build
the developer ecosystem,
and the work we have with
development agencies,
we want to ensure that the
next generation of startups
is as successful as it can be.
So I'm very excited to announce
our new Launchpad Accelerator
program.
We're going to be giving select
startups in India, Indonesia,
and Brazil grant seed funding
as well as close mentorship
from Google, from
Google Developers,
and Google engineers,
and product managers,
as well as some of the best
mentors from around the world.
We will fly these teams
to Google headquarters
in California in Silicon Valley,
for them to start a six month
training program.
We have already selected
our first class,
and we're now looking to see
who our next batch of startups
will be.
So if you have a great team and
a killer idea, please apply.
So these are just
some of the programs
that we at Google have to
help you be successful.
Now I'm going to bring
on Francis Ma who's
going to talk about some of
things on the product side
to help you build your
apps and your business.